Michelle Obama says she's terrified
about potential outcome of 2024 election
she's running so uh the other day a top
strategist for JP Morgan said that Joe
Biden will drop out in March following
super Tuesday I believe this makes the
most sense as of right now it doesn't
mean it's absolute but it makes sense
why many people said Joe Biden can't
drop out it's too late to hold a primary
okay but that's actually the best thing
Democrats could do keep Joe Biden in the
race until it is too late to hold a
primary due to a medical issue he is
forced to bow out and then because they
can't have a primary they get to appoint
someone the DNC does by passing the
potential for Marian Williamson RFK Jr
or Jen Huger uh stopping them from
winning the nomination in this instance
with this story emerging of Michelle
Obama now popping up and saying she's
concerned about the outcome of
2024 I think there's a there's a really
great opportunity right now to put a
wager on Michelle Obama winning the
Democrat nomination or being the nominee
against
uh Donald Trump
because well she's terrified about the
potential outcome of 2024 where does
that story go and why is she being asked
exactly because in one month she says my
fear of what's to come in 2024 is so
great I feel like I must do something
about it a month after that Joe Biden
stumbles and Falls Michelle Obama says
my greatest fear has been realized our
great leader Joe Biden has fallen ill
someone tied his shoes
tripped and now he can't be president
anymore a month later she says I must do
my duty to prevent my greatest fear from
coming to fruition I must run for the
presidency yeah exactly it's
self-sacrificing and every politician
has to have a narrative like this we saw
this with Joe Biden the reason I ran for
president was because of Charlottesville
I saw what happened on television and I
said I need to run I I need I saw
Charlottesville happening and said I
need to be the one running this country
it's like all right Joe but that's the
story that he went with and they all try
to have their own little origin story uh
and so this is clearly hers she said I'm
just so nervous about what's happening
Donald Trump he's a criminal they're
going to let this man be president if
she runs I think she wins do you really
think so I I would I would have thought
that um a year or so ago I'm not as
convinced you are blackpilled man I no I
mean look at she's she's going to go you
think she wins the general election yeah
she she goes and she sits down with
Oprah and then like all your soccer moms
all your wine moms are voting for I mean
the only people that won't vote for her
are people that have actual grievance so
the people that are really poed about
things the people that have kids that
have dealt with uh LGBT issues at
schools those people are not going to
switch because uh because she's running
but people that are just people that are
lightly involved in politics that are
middle that are middle class that that
generally aren't feeling the effects of
the economy or
inflation I I I I disagree for one
simple reason these liberal-minded
Suburban moms I don't think would vote
for a black woman I think they're the
reason they believe Dei stuff is because
they're overtly racist I believe that
the only way you end up with someone
preaching about racism but then actually
pushing for segregation like I saw in
Sweden is that they're deeply racist and
they're trying to prove they're not but
in private they're going to be as racist
as they can be look look at look at all
of these like these liberal
personalities who say racist things
behind closed doors and they busted for
it or whatever like I shouldn't say all
these but like numerous stories over the
past few years and sexist things as well
I'd be willing to bet all of these
liberal you know Democrat wine mobs in
the suburbs would be like oh yeah I'll
vote for Michelle Obama and then
privately like ain't no way I'm doing
that I'm voting for Donald Trump Tina
Fay in 30 in third in 30 Rock I was
going to say Third Rock From the Sun in
30 Rock not the alien one said in the
first season I tell my friends I voted
for Barack Obama but I secretly voted
for John
McCain M I think a lot of people will
claim they're voting for Michelle Obama
and then they'll be shocked when it's
actually a narrow race and she doesn't
do as well as people think not to
mention I don't think that the Nostalgia
factor is going to play as well as they
would hope Joe Biden came in he trashed
everything and the issue now is it's not
even necessarily about the person it's
about the party Joe Biden as a Democrat
the Democrats have done so poorly that
Michelle Obama could run and she'll do
better than Biden that's a fact but I
don't know if it's enough to overcome
Trump's success in the polls right now
yeah also I think one massive uh mistake
that the Democrats have made over the
past two years is they've actually
turned parents into a voting Block in a
way that we've never seen before they've
been like well you know I just want to
you know if you're against porn being
shown to children in schools you're a
big bad farite extremist and then a
bunch of parents went all right well I
guess I'm a big bad far-right extremist
then because I would rather be that than
allow you perverts to groove my children
and uh here we are no you're both wrong
she'll
win you think so oh yeah I I I do I and
and that's not obviously clearly like
I'm not like endorsing Michelle Obama
the like I'm I'm endorsing at least
until the primary I'm like I'm going to
vote for V in the primary because he's
the guy that's talking about cutting the
government most whoever is talking about
cutting the government most is who I'm
going to vote for I don't know man I
think you're endorsing Michelle you
really seem to want her to win well
anyways uh you can think that and it's
cute but um I like to think here that
Tim is right I would love it I would
love it I would I would like to be wrong
this is not some kind of thing where I'm
like oh man this is what I'm hoping for
I would love to be wrong but like I said
I am blackpilled as hell on on what the
American people want because I don't see
as much as we're seeing push back
against the the people that are are are
complaining about Palestine and
protesting uh and stuff I don't see
enough push back from your normal people
to for me to be like oh the general
consensus is not the left leaning
consensus like the Soma of life and
everything is just so much there's just
no nothing really pushing them to really
feel like hey I got to do something
about this hey I'm going to stand up and
say something I I know I'm traveling
around even in my own State you know I'm
seeing people that are just being
crushed by biomics and inflation and
it's a constant talk I've done over 50
town halls and what what you just said I
think Rings true that people are just so
fed up with Democrats and Democratic
Leadership and the lack thereof and how
worse off they are today than they were
under President Trump I hear that a lot
I hope there's enough of them I hope so
too but that is an interesting thought
or comment about how people are uh so
many Democrats are innately racist
themselves and and we saw that with you
just made me think of um the immigrants
that they flew to Martha's Vineyard
right right exactly to see how quickly
within what was it 24 hours they just
went ahead and so there was there was
that Yale study several years ago that
found
liberals Dro their vocabulary level when
speaking to black people that's right
and conservatives do not and that's it's
really obvious why Democrats well
they've always been racist I mean it's
quite literally their party platform
since the early days but they're like
hey we switched the kind of racism that
we have yeah they're still racist and so
if you have your average liberal who
encounters a black person and then tries
to sound stupid on purpose it's crazy
they're basically saying they think
black people are stupid whereas
conservatives just talk to them like
normal people because they just think
they're normal people it's really you
think a person who who does that is
going to look at Michelle Obama and
think that's the person they want to
lead the country they may publicly act
like they oppose racism but from their
own actions they show that they actually
look down on minorities and when it
comes to the private decision-making
process they're going to brag to the
High Heavens I just voted for Michelle I
actually voted for Trump but I'm not
telling my friends that because I'll get
made fun of they're GNA vote for Trump
yeah now the challenge I think Trump has
with a lot of these women though is that
he's like nasty mhm a lot of these
liberal Democrat women's are like he
grosses me out and so going to be put to
the test of whether or not to be more
racist or disgusted and whether or not
like what which will play a bigger role
I got to be honest I think many of these
Democrats are so racist they would say
well I'm disgusted by Trump but they'd
vote for him because that's how racist I
think they are that they wouldn't want
to vote for Michelle and I'm not saying
every single one what we see in the data
from this study is that a a decent
amount of liberals will lower their
vocabulary level yeah when talking to
black people because they assume black
people are stupid I mean look at the
voter ID thing Amy Horwitz with one of
the greatest political videos ever made
have you seen this one yeah he goes
around asking black people he goes to
Berkeley and he says do you think voter
ID is RAC like yeah of course because
black people don't know how to get the
internet and can't get IDs and then he
just goes to Black Neighbors in New York
and he's like do you have an ID and
they're like yeah and he's like do you
have the internet and I love this Teena
this like 20-year-old guy's like what do
you mean even a 13-year-old kid got the
internet yeah my favorite though was
when he asks the guy one of the Berkeley
kids says they don't it's hard for them
to get to the DMV they don't know where
it is and then he asks his older black
gu's like can I ask you a question do
you know where the DMV is and he goes
yeah it's over there in 26 he's going to
go down here you make a like the guy was
asking for directions it was such a
stupid question to ask a guy he assumed
the guy needed help finding it yeah dude
it's it's hilarious um those people are
going to vote for Michelle yeah right I
mean a lot of these I they might because
it'll make them feel better about
themselves and absolve themselves if
they're like
racis hilarious to me is that you know
so for example like as a voice actor
someone who does voices for cartoons
they'll say about me and other voice
actors like you could never do a black
voice but then every time they talk to a
black person they try to do this weird
impression of how black people speak and
this is exactly what that study's
talking about they'll do that they'll
like start using black slang and they'll
as the studies literally show they will
use a dumb down vocabulary it's like
this is insanely insulting and then you
get bent out of shape over like a
comedian doing an impression of a black
person as a j when you're actually
trying to do it in real life you think
that's how you should communicate with
group of people so I so there are times
when I'm on tour where I have to go on
vocal rest and I'm not allowed to talk
right so like people walk in the room
and I can't say anything everyone must
hate that it's super Annoying It's the
most annoying thing in the world but
people constantly come up and they don't
know how to talk because I can't talk to
them and what the and so what they start
doing is they start whispering or they
try to sign I'm like and it's like I'm
the one that can't talk dummy and I
wonder if that's the same kind of thing
they think that the person they're
interacting with is is unable to so they
try if that it's the same kind of like
uh um not like if they're not thinking
about it it's the same kind of reaction
so anyways that's I just thought it was
funny but yeah no absolutely that's that
that's hilarious thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time